- SHE'S BEEN DEAD
MAYBE TEN MINUTES.
- LIKE HEAD CHOPPED OFF.
- NO, SHE DIED OF, LIKE,
NATURAL CAUSES.
- I'D DO IT, MAN.
SHE WAS CUTE AS HELL
IN COMMANDO.
I'D SHOW HER WHO'S THE BOSS.
POISON HER IVY.
- WHOA. SOMETHING'S UP.
- GUYS, WE'VE BEEN
BOILER ROOMED.
TELAMERICORP WAS JUST A SHELL
OF A COMPANY.
ALICE PROBABLY FELT
SOME HEAT FROM THE FEDS, RIGHT?
SO SHE PACKED UP
IN THE MIDDLE OF THE NIGHT.
THAT MAKES ME VIN DIESEL.
- OOH, I'M GIOVANNI RIBISI.
- OH, I'M LIKE A SCOTT CANN-
JAMIE KENNEDY COMBO DOGGIE THEN.
- JAMIE KENNEDY, MAYBE.
I FEEL THAT EXPERIENCE.
[cell phone rings]
- HELLO?
[whispers]
IT'S ALICE.
OKAY, LET'S TALK.
WHAT'S THE VIG
TO GET IN ON YOUR GAME?
- WHY AREN'T YOU HERE YET?
[snaps fingers]
- WHY AREN'T WE WHERE YET?
- OH, CHRIST, YOU'RE AT
THE OLD OFFICES, AREN'T YOU?
WE MOVED OFFICES
OVER THE WEEKEND.
IT'S ALL I'VE TALKED ABOUT
FOR WEEKS.
- GUYS, WE MOVED OFFICES.
- OH, YEAH, I TOTALLY FORGOT.
- YEAH, UM, ALICE...
- OH, WAIT, WAIT, LET ME--
HEY, ALICE, SO WE'RE DONE
WITH THE OLD OFFICE, RIGHT?
WE'RE NEVER GOING BACK?
- YEAH, NEVER.
NOW, GET YOUR ASSES OVER HERE
AND GET TO WORK, PLEASE.
- OKAY, THANKS, ALICE.
YOU SOUND LIKE
YOU'RE LOOKING GOOD TODAY.
[pounding rock music]
OH, YEAH!
[all shouting]
- ♪ DESTROY
♪ DESTROY
- I FEEL LIKE
I'M AT A GARTH BROOKS SHOW.
- KICK IT.
HE'S TALENTED.
[all shouting]
[laughter]
[cell phone rings]
- HELLO?
OH, HEY, ALICE.
HOW ARE YOU?
WHAT'S UP?
- HEY, IF YOU'RE STILL
AT THE OFFICE,
CAN YOU LET THE INSPECTOR IN?
HE'S LOCKED OUT.
I DON'T WANT TO
PISS HIM OFF
AND NOT GET THE $8,000
SECURITY DEPOSIT BACK.
- UM, NO, NO, NO, NO.
YOU MUST HAVE
MISUNDERSTOOD US.
WE ARE NOT AT THE OLD OFFICE.
WE ARE WATCHING
THE OLD OFFICE, THE TV SHOW,
ON AN iPAD IN THE CAR
ON THE WAY TO THE NEW OFFICE.
- WHAT? HELLO?